我想近這一個月來
我想很多人都關心這個
美國、以色列和伊朗的戰爭
一個牽動世界局勢的戰爭
今天我也想用這個作為一個開始
不過就從另外一個角度
我覺得戰爭是一個平台
你可以看到人在這方面的發明是很厲害的
在這次的戰爭裡面 你看到各樣不同的武器
不知道大家有沒有留意時事
在這個左上角 被稱為MOAB
就是Mother of all Bomb
就是常規武器裡面最厲害的一個炸彈
甚至投彈的時候要用G170大力士運輸機的
因為太重太大
因為這個mother of all bomb
是常規武器裡面最厲害的
就是說如果你要提升那個戰力
你就要用這個非常規武器
比如說核彈等等
那就用到很盡了
旁邊那個就是鑽地彈
因為你知道伊朗有很多那些地下的導彈城
地下的核設施
投射這些轉彈的就是這個B-2轟炸機
左手邊下面那張就是
那個是一個鱼雷來的
一個Mk 48超重的鱼雷
我想你都還記得在印度洋
有一架伊朗的護衛艦在印度演習完
就回伊朗在途中被美國的潛艇擊沉
其實這架護衛艦不是很大也不是很先進的
其實打它可以用飛彈都可以的
有時候用飛彈你還會給它時間能夠逃生
但是他們竟然用到這個魚雷
你看見在YouTube裡面
你可以看見很快就沉了
當斯蘭卡的舊船艦去到的時候
其實船已經沉了
那為什麼會用到超重魚雷去對付它呢?
聽說當日在美國的潛艇
那個叫洛杉磯級的潛艇
有兩個澳洲的海軍人員接受訓練
那你知道澳洲就買了美國的核潛艇
也都某程度就默許了
如果太平洋第一島鏈有什麼事
澳洲就會出兵
所以其實當日在潛艇裡面
應該也是一個實戰訓練來的
而旁邊那個呢 都很厲害
那個叫石墨彈
就是說它威脅炸伊朗的發電廠
你發覺不是傷害民生的東西
因為他們發覺有一個現象就是
在一些鄉村、在一些人口少的地方
大概用電量很高
很可能就是背後有一些核設施
又說有一些軍事設施
所以他們為什麼美國要求
要脅說要炸這個發電廠
但是如果炸了發電廠就不得了
影響很多人、影響民生
所以這個石墨彈是什麼呢?
就是它一投入的時候
那些石墨本身使得很多短路發生
就使得它輸不了電
但是那個發電廠和那些發電設施
是沒有被摧毀的
你可以看到是不是很厲害
其實這些的戰爭科技
又例如美國的無人機
Lucas 無人機
另外無人快艇、無人艇
你看到左下角有一個叫做 Starshield
其實這個也是 SpaceX 的
Starlink 就是為民用的
Starshield 就是為軍用的
所以你發覺如果拆開那些無人機的機頭
有一些接收器的
那就是那些Starshield的導航來的
另外在這個右手邊的上角
那個就是激光炮
其實近年呢 由2023年開始
他們很流行的一件事情就是所謂的飽和攻擊
用一些很便宜的武器 比如說無人機
或者一些很便宜的導彈
這樣呢
以下的導彈是更加貴的
我想你都聽過就是1比100
就是說那個導彈的價值
是那個無人機的100倍
那就是人家出豉油
點都點乾你了
所以你發覺呢
在這次裡面你看到很多很便宜的
從這些武器裡面
你可以看到科技相當先進
曾經有人說 人發明的武器
從來都沒有在戰場上不被應用的
而事實上在戰爭歷史裡面
武器呢 我可以說有幾次的
有三次的革命的發展的
那我就很想用這個叫做骨幹講一下
如果有人問你 在歷史裡面
最大的帝國是哪一個呢?
不知道你會不會說是蒙古帝國 正確的
因為在歐亞一大片的裡面
蒙古帝國橫跨歐亞大陸是很大片
那為什麼他們能夠這麼厲害呢?
蒙古最厲害的就是它的騎兵
我覺得這幅畫裡面
當我找到這幅畫
我覺得這幅畫的人
他都相當認識蒙古的騎兵的
為什麼呢?
因為蒙古兵其中一樣的厲害就是它的弓
那個弓有名的叫反曲弓
你看那兩邊是不是勾出來的
比起當時的十三世紀的弓
強成三、四倍的
近距離可以射穿盔甲的
另外還有一樣東西就是馬燈
就是說上馬的時候那個腳踏那個馬燈
雖然馬燈不是蒙古人發明的
但是馬燈的功用蒙古就將它發揮到極致
為什麼呢?因為由於馬燈的緣故
那個騎馬的人能夠站在馬背上
而他可以在360度去射箭
去壓制著對方 因為有馬燈有這麼強的弓
所以有一招很出名的就是回馬戰
你不要以為它敗走你追著它
它轉頭就可以拿你命了
所以你看見蒙古在13世紀
橫掃沒有人能夠去打
第一次的武器的革命是什麼呢?
就是人們用火藥 將火藥應用在軍事上面
那就出現了這個火槍 另外就是火炮
所以如果有人問你 最大的帝國
其實 算面積不是蒙古 算面積
你都很熟的了 就是什麼呢?
就是日不落帝國 就是大英帝國
就是在歷史中
算面積最大的就是大英帝國
這個就是第一次的
在戰爭上、武器上的革命
如果有人跟你講三分熟、五分熟
或者全熟 你會想起什麼呢?
可能你會想起是不是教人煎牛扒呢?
其實這個是一個 jargon 來的
是一個 term 來的
就是某國、某大國 即美國
美國一旦如果遇到核攻擊
所作出的反應的一個選項來的
到底三分熟、五分熟是全熟呢?
其實講的就不是牛扒 而是地球
即是一旦受到攻擊 受到核攻擊
作出的反應到底是同歸於盡呢?
還是怎樣的回應呢?
所以第二個革命在武器史上
就是核子彈的發明
那你知道核子彈發明了之後
沒有多久就投了兩顆在日本
而美國相當強 到現在都是了
那麽核子彈呢 我覺得都還有兩樣東西是很特別的
第一就是什麽呢? 就是你要有這個核燃料
而這些核燃料呢 基本上不是那麽容易得到的
譬如現在伊朗呢 它很想成為擁有核武的國家
但是要提煉 要得到這些的核燃料不是那麽容易的
再加上在國際上有所謂核不擴散條約
所以由1945年到現在
其實都只有10個國家是擁有核子的武器
即是核子的能力而已
不過一提你發覺就最後那兩個
我都打了一年份了 不知道你看不看得到
最後那兩個成為核國家的是什麼?
最後那個就是北韓 2006年
接著再上一個就是巴基斯坦
好了 今天我們的聚會有一個題目
有個名字叫做機械殺手
或者叫做殺手機械人
其實機械人在生活上面
在很多方面已經影響到大家了
比如這裡 你看見左上角那個就是Waymo
有沒有搭過你們那邊 有沒有
比如你在LA downtown
你很快就會見到的了
就是那些無人駕駛的士
Waymo很容易認的
車頂、兩邊有很多感應器的
另外旁邊那個就是Shake Shack的那些
送文件、送食物的機器人
有些機器人比如這個Optimus
就是Tesla的
最近美國的新聞就是
它現在開始坐這個Counter
譬如在LA這裡有一個地方叫做Diamond Bar
它的City Hall就是這個機器人
你一靠近它 它就會問你
它能夠幫到你什麼
那些機器人也都幫忙執法
數了幾天我就看到這輛車
不知道你有沒有留意這些科技
叫做Cybercab
其實呢 Waymo 就是Google的
而Cybercab呢 就是這個Tesla的
那我就不其而問一問題了
那既然都不是什麼特別
就是無人駕駛的的士
那這個Cybercap有什麼特別呢?
有沒有留意?
那我在街上看到他試車
這個就是特別之處了
就是沒有胎盤的
也都沒有國際的
那如果是所謂的龍飛船
SpaceX那些接人去國際太空站的飛船
其實就是這樣的了
你上船只有一個tablet在那裡
只有一個tablet在那裡
那就連軚盤都沒有的
所以不知道有什麼事都不知道怎麼辦
今天我們講殺手機系人
Killer Robot
其實這個是一個俗稱來的
它的學名其實是什麼呢?
就是一個Lethal Autonomous Weapon
就是致命的、自主的武器
顧名思義就是一個武器
不過它有兩個要素
第一就是它配備致命的武器
第二樣東西是什麼呢?
它是自主的,一會兒我們會講到
所以殺手機械人
其實它就是具備這兩個特點
第一 它有致命的武器
第二就是它自主
那不知道你心目中
殺手機器人是怎麼樣的呢?
會不會是這樣的呢?
曾幾何時有些戲呢
Terminator 或者 Robocop 你都見到類似的
但是這些都是拍片
近似一些現實的就是比如Big Dog
在上面有一支槍
又或者有一些履帶的機器人
那你說 不是的 不是的
我在電視上看到那些機器人
那些殺手機器人不是這樣的 是這樣的
我在電視上 最近春晚我才見過這些殺手機器人
懂得打醉拳的
其實人形的機器人就未必最有優勢的
因為你兩隻腳一定是不會夠四隻腳跑得快的
另外加上如果地形是凹凸的一個方面
我想你都不夠那些履带車走得夠穩妥這樣
其實除了伊朗戰爭之外
還有一場戰爭 北京、北角已經打了四年多了
就是俄羅斯烏克蘭的戰爭
在上年裏面就曾經有這樣的一幕的
就是有一些俄羅斯的軍人
他就投降了 他就向一些部隊投降
但是那些部隊是沒有真人的
全部是機械人來的
不知道你有沒有留意這個新聞
我在YouTube裏面看到
我不知道你還找不找得到
當時是怎樣呢?當時有架無人機
烏克蘭的無人機
飛過上去在戰壕上面
就發現有些俄羅斯的士兵
有些士兵向那個無人機開槍
接著沒多久就有一架戰車
就是你見到的螢幕上面右邊的下面那個
其實那架車是什麼呢?
其實那架車是炸彈來的
四個輪子炸彈就駛到戰壕那裡
就想一锅熟的
但是那些俄羅斯的士兵看到這樣就扯白旗
就表示投降
接著那架有機槍的戰車就出現了
就將他們繳械
以及將他們押回去這個俘虜營了
你覺得這樣都可以嗎?
其實如果你留意一下新聞
你就知道這四年裡面
使烏克蘭成為一個在軍事上都是一個強國
特別是什麼呢?就是那些無人機的系統
比如無人的飛機、無人的車、無人的戰車、無人的艦艇
那無人的艦艇也很出名的 為什麼呢?
因為它壓制著黑海艦隊的
就是俄羅斯的黑海艦隊
而控制這些的無人機械的時候
通常就是用一個叫做First Person View
就是說第一身的視覺
就是說那個飛機看到的東西
那個鏡頭看到的東西 就是你看到的東西了
就好像畫面你見到的
那個控制的人 他就是這樣了
他看到的就是那個無人機鏡頭裡面
拍攝到的情況了這樣
由2024年的年尾開始
在烏克蘭的戰場裏面
他們就已經開始了實行這個所謂協同作戰
一個士兵、一個單兵
他不單止是控制陸上的戰車
他也都可以同時控制空中的那些無人機
所以有監察 剛才那個例子
他發現那些俄兵
接著就可以調動一架炸彈車去到中間
歼敵了 這樣
那你可以看到就是協同作戰
使它一個單兵能夠控制這個
海陆空的無人的那些武器
再加上就是人工智能在這幾年裡面
就是在戰場上面的發展
就使得它那個果效更加厲害
用機械人的果效 為什麼呢?
因為人工智能可以將大量偵測到的資料
海量的資料能夠消化、能夠分析
從而判斷到戰場的情況
繼而提供一些的選項
所以你有沒有留意近這幾個月
你會覺得美軍是不是很厲害?
比如捉馬杜羅這樣 一晚幾個小時
竟然就抓到 其實在中南美洲
委內瑞丹算是一個軍事強國來的
但是這樣一抓就抓到了
明天我舉多個例子 你們會了解
那就不知道大家有沒有看過這齣戲
這齣戲叫做《Zero Dark Thirty》
有些人誉为說
如果你要看戰爭片
十大其中一齣就是這樣了
《Zero Dark Thirty》是什麼呢?
中文我想你很熟了
通常那些人的軍事行動
他們就會選擇12點鐘至3點
因為生理時鐘告訴我們
大部分的人12點鐘至3點
就是他最脆弱的、最睏的時候
所以0.30 就是說12點半
即午夜30分的行動的意思
其中有這樣的一幕的
話說這個中央情報局的女探員
就找到這個賓拉登藏在巴基斯坦
但是就一直上級就沒有行動了
沒有行動 為什麼呢?
因為她怕引起外交風波
她就經常問到底有多少成肯定
賓拉登是在那裡呢?在大宅那裡呢?
這一幕就是那個旅程服務員
就每一天去到上司門口那裡就寫下了
比如今天就寫下21天
找到這個大宅已經21天了
還沒有行動這樣
一直去到什麼?去到159天
就是四個多月都沒有行動
最後才落槌
而我想這次的伊朗戰爭裡面
我覺得最嚇人的是什麼呢?就是第一天
是吧?第一天就已經斬殺了這個哈梅內伊了
不僅如此 在第一天裡面已經殺了
48個高級的將領和一些重要的領袖
很厲害 很厲害
那為什麼他能夠這樣做呢?
除了武器精準之外
所以你看見左手邊的上面
哈梅內伊的住宅是不是很精準打擊?
那棟樓就塌了
還有幾個洞是很深的
因為它是用鑽地彈那一類的
而附近的那些樓宇是沒有被摧毀的
其實就是什麼呢?
就是它利用很多的監察
比如馬路的那些鏡頭
用很多監察 當然利用人工智能去分析
將所有的目標人物已經到場了
接著就決定用什麼時候
是不是把這個時候去出擊呢?
還有當出擊的時候 用什麼武器呢?
你也留意到有聽過所謂用這個
Blue Sparrow 藍雀 藍麻雀
這個武器是很特別的 為什麼呢?
因為一般的飛彈一發射就向前的
但是它是向上的
它就衝出去這個大氣的邊緣
在太空的邊緣
為什麼這樣呢?
第一就是在太空邊緣阻力少
就是說它能夠射的射程更加遠
還有當它再回到地面的時候
進入這個大氣層的時候
它俯衝下來那個速度快
就攔截的機會就少了
你明白嗎?
其實還有一個原因的
因為你看見這個是戰爭第一天
就是戰爭的初期
其實你都不知道伊朗的防空系統被鎮壓
被摧毀了多少的
所以它就是針對這件事來選擇這件武器的
因為你知道雷達無論你外面怎麼看
它裡面都有一個天線是360度旋轉
其實原理就是這麼簡單
就是你發射一些信號上去
出去 然後它遇到些什麼就回頭
那你不就知道前面的事情了
那是不是360度啊?
但是大部分的雷達都有一個盲點的
那個盲點是什麼呢?就是它的天頂
就是它的頭頂
你很少見到那些雷達在高高頭地掃的
明白嗎?
所以這個南麻竹有一個特點就是什麼呢?
它正正就在天頂那裡
在你頭頂就崩下來
所以為什麼開戰第一天?
我想給你看的是什麼呢?
無論那些情報 那些情報的分析
那些時間的把握 還有那些武器運作
其實都是經過人工智能的消化而作出決定
所以那個成績是很顯然的
好了 面對著這些無人的武器
其實都有對策的
這一張大家看不看到是什麼?
你看這個城市
好像是不是有一層蜘蛛網在上面
這個就是烏克蘭東部的一個城鎮的情況
那些是什麼來的呢?
其實就是當一個無人機
它放了上天空的時候
它就是透過一些電波
跟這個控制員保持聯絡的
那怎麼對付它呢?
它就發一些的Jamming signal
就是說一些電子的干擾系統
那你一旦失去了聯絡
那就控制不了了
你明白嗎?那怎麼解決這個問題呢?
怎麼解決這個問題呢?它就用光纖
用一些fiber optic的光纖
將無人機就連上去了
這樣之後它是不受電波干擾的
而透過光纖一樣可以傳送到
第一就是可以控制到那個無人機
另外就是可以傳送到那個景象
你仍然可以用第一聲去控制它
你明白我的意思嗎?
而那些光纖是很長的 幾十里的
每一次都幾十里的
如果毀滅了目標之後
那些光纖就留在戰場上面
所以久而久之 整個戰場就好像蜘蛛網一樣
你見到那些光纖就是這樣
如果你知光纖的性質不容易斷的 你明白嗎?
不過你可以想像到有相當的問題
除了在戰場上遺留了這麼多光纖之外
另外就是你走多長都是幾十里而已
怎麼能夠解決這個問題呢?
怎麼能夠解決這個電波干擾的問題呢?
在幾個星期之前在這個
Foreign Affairs 的雜誌裡面就有一篇報道
這個人寫的其實是很出名的
就是他是一個四星上將來的
也都是CIA的前局長
他就寫了一篇文章講到就是自主戰場
什麼意思呢?他就說了
其實最後打贏一場仗
不在乎那個國家它擁有多少無人機
多少無人武器
而是在乎那些無人的武器是怎樣決策的
如果當你發現了對方
而到開火之前仍然要人呢?要士兵呢?
按那個攻擊制的時候
你這個操作、你這個反應已經太慢了
你明白我的意思嗎?
所以你看見其實現在烏克蘭
左邊那個Interceptor就是烏克蘭研發出來的
也都幫助這個海灣國家對付伊朗的那些無人機
右手邊那個就是美國發明的那些無人機
這個無人機的特點是什麼呢?
第一就是它是AI導航的
它的pilot是AI的
就是說呢 當你放他上去的時候呢
你就給了他任務
他就會執行這個任務了
當你放他上去空中的時候呢
他們都期望什麼呢?
就是很快就失去聯絡的了 因為有干擾嘛
但是你給了一個指令他
他就會執行了 他怎麼樣?
他就會自動尋找目標
然後將他擊落
以後這幾個情況之下呢
它可能會發生的 第一就是什麼呢?
就是它找的目標已經被摧毀了
那它就會安全的回航
又或者什麼呢?
就是它找一個另一個 當它的目標被摧毀之後
它找一個另外一個目標 它自己執行的
找一個另外一個目標 然後去摧毀它
又或者什麼呢?
又或者你再一次聯絡上這個無人機
改變它或者給它另外一個指令
明白什麼意思嗎?
簡單來說 你一旦放了它上空中
它就自我執行那個指令
不用到最後放炸彈的時候
你要再按一下 不用的了
它就會自己執行這個這樣的指令了
跟不跟得到?
我覺得這個就是那個問題的所在
因為一直以來所謂的殺手機械人
他們都有一條紅線的
那條紅線是什麼呢?
就是最後當決定開火的時候
到底這個控制權在哪裡?
是那個控制的士兵呢?
還是你交給人工智能去決定呢?
這個就是那條紅線 這個就是那個紅鍵
而剛才你看到的是什麼呢?
因為戰場上這樣的原因
發展這些無人機、無人的系統
而它要面對這個Jamming signal的時候
它就給它一個這樣的安排 就是什麼呢?
你一旦放上去 你就自己執行任務
AI就是你的導航了 你明白嗎?
有些人就有個問題 就是
嘩 這樣還得了的 之後一放上去
他就自己找對象了 自己開火了
那他知不知道找那些是什麼人來的?
他知不知道這樣是對還是錯的?
行不行的?
但是你要知道呢
在幾年、四年以來俄烏戰爭裡面
其實烏克蘭他最想的是什麼?
就是打贏這場仗
至於這些到底道不道德?
合不合適呢?留在大學裡面辯論
你明白嗎?所以不知不覺呢
這一條紅線就被逾越了
那就締造了什麼呢?締造了剛才我們講的
殺手機械人有兩個特點
第一就是它配備致命的武器
槍也好、炸彈也好
第二就是什麼呢?它能夠自主的執行
慢慢你看見現在這個界線越來越模糊了
越來越模糊的 如果你留意新聞
其實最近有一個AI公司
與美國的戰爭部打官司的
就是因為他們很執著
覺得那些人工智能要在戰場上
發揮到一個程度去到哪裡
它覺得是不能夠讓它自主的
那戰爭部當然說
我們不能夠接受一家這樣的公司
所以就取消了它的合約
於是現在就在打官司
那你可看到的是什麼呢?
這個就是那個趨勢
這個我相信也是前面
戰爭武器的第三次革命來的
有別於核子武器是什麼呢?
因為這些材料是很容易得到的
你甚至用3D打印機
都可以打出這些武器出來的
所以最近你有沒有聽過一個新聞就是什麼?
就是北京禁止那些人 禁止那些無人機飛行
禁止那些無人機改裝 其實很簡單的
只要製造一架無人機 放一些炸藥下去
就可以有斬首行動的了
所以有別於核子武器
就是那些材料是更加普遍 更加容易擴散
而現在的烏克蘭呢 其實你上網找一下
它每年可以製作的無人機是數以百萬計的
由戰爭開始的時候 今上沒什麼軍工業
到現在一年可以出數以百萬計的無人機
好了 這樣你說了
其實這些武器的革命、武器的發展
跟我們有什麼關係呢?
在《啟示錄》中在《聖經》中
講到將來的災難
剛才唱那首歌的時候,我有一個感覺的
因為主祂曾經救我們,祂仍要救我們
祂曾經救我們脫離罪惡
祂也要救我們脫離災難
而先講到將來的災難
其中一樣東西就是死很多人
特別是指著兩個時候
第一個時候就是揭開印的時候
揭開頭那幾印的時候
就好像這個說的
他說揭開第四印的時候
我聽到第四個活物就說
他說你來 我就觀看
見到有一匹灰馬 骑在馬上的有個名叫做死
陰府隨著牠 有權柄賜給牠們
可以用刀劍饑荒瘟疫 野獸
殺害地上四分一的人
那麼之前牠有三匹馬的
有一匹白馬、一匹紅馬、一匹黑馬
那其實就是回應之前那裡
那把紅馬就是刀劍 即是打仗
那把黑馬就是什麼呢?就是饑荒
也都有瘟疫 不知道
那麼我覺得這些瘟疫有可能是
也都跟軍事有些關係都未定的
比如現在你看見就是
COVID-19 這樣 一直以來都
有些人不想人追查那個源頭
但是也都有不少的證據顯示
是很可能是來自這個實驗室的
這樣 你知道上規武器 剛才我們講過一些
那麼非上規武器除了核彈之外
另外就有生化武器的 這樣
這個講到用刀劍饑荒瘟疫
野獸殺了地上四分之一人
現在全世界80多億人
死了四分之一知道什麼?死了20億人
中國13億、美國3億多
只要說中美的人搭上去
都不夠填這條數的
你明白嗎?這樣
那為什麼會死這麼多人呢?
其實聖經也都講到
那場仗會有一個很厲害的火
比如三分之一的地燒了 所有的青草燒了
三分之一的海洋受打擊 三分之一的日月星辰
我相信就不是太陽月亮有什麼問題
而是大氣層 它大氣層就出了狀況受影響
那什麼會使得世界三分之一的地、三分之一的海
三分之一的大氣受影響呢?
我覺得很可能就是跟這個核戰有關
在下個禮拜裏面
我們也會講到這方面多一些的
因為為什麼呢?
因為你可能會覺得就是聖經是神的話
但是聖經很古老
那既然聖經這麼古老
它怎麼講到這些現代才有的名詞呢?
你明白嗎?現代才有的狀況呢?
其實都能夠表達到的
我們這方面下一次可以講得多一些
但是起碼你知道在1月、2月的時候
是不是美國還在講一個話題
就是想拿這個格陵蘭
完成它那個金窮頂的防禦計劃
可能有些人覺得就是什麼
就是核彈是由東向西飛、由西向東飛
但是你有沒有想過其實它可以向北飛
橫跨北極的 它的航道是更加短的
比如現在有一些航線 飛機的航線
其實都是飛越北極的
所以這個就牽涉到核子武器的形容了
最近都多了很多這樣的東西的
關乎到核戰、核彈的攔截等等
再回應那句
人發明的武器從來都沒有不用的
而現在的核彈
是比起當日的廣島長崎的威力是千倍以上
好了 剛才你說的殺手機械人有什麼呢?
這樣在聖經裏面 提到第九章
有這樣的一個描述的
就講到有幾個天使吹號 有七個天使吹號
第六個天使吹號的時候
他說有聲音從神面前 神的面前
金壇四角就出來了 講什麼呢?
他說要將他捆綁在幼法拉底河的
四個使者釋放出來
那四個使者就被釋放了
他們原來準備好
到某年、某月、某日、某時
要殺人的三分之一
馬軍有二萬萬
他的數目我聽見了
第二道說到死很多人的就是這裡
殺人的三分之一,如果按剛才這樣算
先是那四匹馬死了四分之一人
全世界只剩下60億人 死了40億
60億裡面再死三分之一 又死了20億
就是說去到這裡的時候
全世界已經沒有了一半人了
我這樣跟你說 其實這個時候是什麼時候?
這個時候就是七年災難的一半的時候
末後的災難都還沒發生
後三年半都還沒發生
所以講到最後那3年半 聖經怎麼說呢?
它說如果不是為了選民、為了以色列人的緣故
減少這些日子 所有有血氣的都不能存留
那你又會知道 其實前面的日子的災難
那個殺傷人的情況是很嚴重的
而剛才我們講的那四個印
就是七年災難開始沒多久
白馬之後而發生的
而這裏這個第六位天使吹號
就是什麼呢?可以這樣說就是
經過了那四匹馬之後
到後來有一個敵基督
就是獸的國出現了
要有人拜祂
而對付異己的殺戮來的
對付異己的殺戮來的
那麽這一次裏面你發覺
除了說殺人的三分之一 死很多人之外
還有兩個特點很特別的
第一就是你發覺他是某年某月某日某時
很有趣的 他沒有說那些兵從哪裡來
要去哪裡打什麼仗
很多人就將他混淆了
跟其他的哈密吉多頓或者其他的混淆了
其實不是的 你看清楚
他已經寫得有相當的暗示
比如他說什麼呢?
他說是源於幼法拉底河的四個使者被釋放
跟靈界有些關係的
而你知道幼法拉底河就是現在的伊拉克
也是以前的巴比倫的地方
回到最初那個反叛的地方
而你發覺它是什麼呢?
某年某月某日某時殺人的三分之一
你們看不看得見呢?
其實不像一場仗來的
只是執行一個指令似的
最近Donald Trump
有一次全國演講 幾天前
他就這樣說了 他說什麼呢?
其實在近代的歷史裡面
從來沒有一場戰爭是打一天的
現在的伊朗戰爭都打了三十多天 整個月了
近代的戰爭從來都沒有打一天、半天的
那麼何況還是某日某時的呢?
所以你覺得像不像執行一個指令?
如果要找對象 執行指令要找對象很容易的
比如你現在看到最近有個新聞就是
比如Facebook、Meta或者其它有些
是被法庭罰它 說它就是用一些的algorithm
用一些的訊息去知道那些人喜歡些什麼
那就供一些東西給它看 就讓它上癮
其實用這些訊息就可以知道你平時
你上網是怎麼樣的情況呢?
就知道你大約是什麼樣的人來的了
你喜歡看什麼 你個人的取向
政治的取向各方面是怎麼樣
那就很容易分辨到那些對象是怎麼樣的了
那另外一件事情一提就是
他說馬軍有2萬萬 即2億
其實現在全世界哪裏有一個國家有2億軍隊?
沒有啊 明白嗎?
但是呢 如果你說
剛才說的那些機械人 殺手機械人
如果要有都不是難的 為什麼呢?
二億 但是他是不是要殺三分一呢?
三分一有二十億啊
那些一個對十個而已 你明白嗎?
所以絕對有這樣的可能
而那些馬軍是怎麼樣的呢?
它在意象中看到的馬是騎馬的
胸前有甲、有火
有甲如火
又有紫玛瑙和硫磺
馬的頭好像獅子頭
好像獅子頭
我知道大家中午現在肚子餓了
這個獅子頭就不是講上海館那些
有火、有煙、有硫磺
從馬的口中出來
這三樣東西就是殺人的三分之一
那馬的能力除了在口之外 也在尾巴
我不知道是什麼
當日約翰他見到的就是這樣了
我自己覺得 環顧現在發展的情況
當然這次的美國、以色列、伊朗的戰爭
還有很多啟發的 在政治上
比如對於歐洲、對於北約
另外對於以色列在中東的位置
這些留待日後有機會再講
但是在武器上面 你可以看到的是什麼呢?
其實美國的經濟、美國的科技
美國的軍事是相當強的
我覺得如果要對付美國
似乎只有一件事就是核武
而當美國和相對的勢力一起step down的時候
你發覺剩下來的很可能的勢力就不多
可能就是歐洲 明白嗎?
而到時有一個的敵對
就是敵基督的國就會出現了
要人拜祂 不拜祂就要死了
這個就是剛才講的第六號的情況
那我覺得武器已經可以說是
你可以看到這些苗頭
那到底前面會怎麼樣呢?
今天我就嘗試用這個武器方面
跟大家講一下這一場戰爭
那麼下一個禮拜呢
我們就會講一下到底前面會怎麼樣呢?
那就不是時事分析的
那麼在《聖經》裡面
它怎麼講前面會發生些什麼呢?
那我們下個禮拜再見啦 好嗎?
那我今天就講